[Music]
see you finished law school mm-hmm
do you work in the law profession before
Hotel San Jose I did indeed
so I went straight from law school to
the DA's office in Manhattan and worked
there for three and a half years or so
and then moved back to Austin and worked
at the attorney general's office so I
was a trial lawyer and again something
I'll never be sorry about
I made amazing friends that I'm still in
in touch with on a regular basis from
from a text thread to occasional
reunions but it also taught me how to
think in a way that has served me really
well in business and and just in the
world it teaches you a former brigham to
be a trial lawyer to understand all the
facts of any situation and again and to
put it together if I look at if I look
at your path side-by-side with the paths
of other former lawyers I know which are
many a lot right okay so maybe they're
they say I don't want to do law but I'm
gonna do management consulting I don't
want to do law I'm going to start a
company with my friend or go to business
school there aren't many who say I don't
want to do law I'm gonna buy a hotel
that's that's full of drug addicts and
prostitutes and so on so why that
particular choice how did that how did
that come to pass yeah I think partially
was serendipity um I was in the right
place at the right time on the right
street what appealed about it to you
because moat for I mean for a lot of
people that would be it would have the
they would have a repellent effect you
had an attractive well if you think
about it come from the DA's office and a
lot of the work I did was with a lot of
this same
I don't know exactly where that
concentric circle is but you know a lot
of the people I dealt with in New York
and in the criminal justice system that
whether it was from a police ride-along
or just looking at the stories of people
every day
down and out orient with in trouble or
you know with when things get cross in
one way or the other in their lives was
not something new for me in that way and
I wasn't scared of that you know junkies
and hookers and you know the like I said
again there were a lot of really good
people there
you